d'ailleurs la ville et 16h38 nous sommes
en direct avec vous pour suivre cette
dixième partie du championnat du monde
d'échecs qui a lieu en ce moment à dubaï
depuis plusieurs jours maintenant depuis
la semaine dernière si je me trompe pas
bertrand c'est ça ça a commencé la
semaine dernière les participes qui se
succèdent de jour en jour on est déjà à
la 10e partie et je ne vous ai pas
encore présenté bertrand guyard qui est
notre spécialiste et chaque ici aux
filières au journaliste culture au
figaro et joueur d'échecs émérite et
spécialistes échec et commentateurs de
parties d'échecs depuis des années aussi
bertrand vous avez l'expérience en ce
domaine comme en savoie bertrand très
bien et vous aussi le vase et les biens
ouais donc jamais que j'avais fait un
plaisir de vous retrouver pour commenter
cette partie qui a eu lieu alors voilà
on avait promis une partie en direct
avec vous cet après midi à 16h30 il
trouve que la partie s'est terminée peu
de temps avant qu'on commence ce direct
elle a été beaucoup plus rapide que
prévu elle a duré environ trois heures
un petit peu moins moins de trois heures
moins de trois heures bon elle a été
relativement rapide puisque certaines
parties précédentes entre les deux
joueurs lors de ce championnat du monde
ont duré huit heures une des parties ce
notamment terminé à dix heures du soir
et du coup ce qu'on essaie de faire
c'est de vous la faire revivre en
accéléré en repassant les coups ensemble
en les commentant donc ça ne change pas
le fond du jeu à vous le connaissez si
vous avez déjà suivi si vous avez déjà
regardé donc précédent live échec state
avec vous bertrand il ya quelques jours
également sur ce championnat du monde
mais c'est égal également avec nous deux
il ya quelques années ça fait des années
qu'on commente les parties d'échecs
notamment les championnats du monde avec
bertrand donc on va bertrand revivre
cette partie et puis on va en profiter
pour faire disons une sorte de débrief à
de ce tournoi en tout cas de ce
championnat de cet affrontement puisque
il touche à sa fin on peut déjà le dire
en tout cas magnus carlsen a un très
sérieux avantage il a fait trois breaks
un sac il a gagné trois parties il reste
un match en 14 parties classiques ca y
reste plus maintenant qu'à quatre
parties à jouer et il faudrait que
quasiment 1 et ponia schiele russes
gagnent trois des quatre dernières
parties pour simplement égaliser le
match donc ce qui serait du jamais vu le
dire à ce stade là un joueur il remonte
en tout cas c'est de l'ordre du miracle
vraiment pour l'emporter oui c'est
difficile de dire c'est du jamais vu
vers 3 pas tout l'historique de tous les
championnats du monde en tête mais en
tout cas ça serait quelque chose de ces
rares je crois qu'il ya peu ce matin je
crois que deux joueurs qui ont réussi à
il ya eu un en préambule il ya eu le
fameux premier match entre karpov et
kasparov que kasparov était mené 5 0
où il a réussi à remonter 5 3 et le
match a été interrompu fin c'était un
match épique mais de toute façon de ne
pas perdre ce match pour un éponyme qui
aujourd'hui se serait de l'ordre de
l'exploit
j'en profite pour vous dire que nous
suivons vos commentaires éventuellement
vos questions vous allez vite c'est
parti avec nous donc n'hésitez pas à
nous les laisser sur le chat du figaro
c'est pour ça que je regarde mon
téléphone c'est parce que je me moque de
ce que dit bertrand c'est pour suivre
vos commentaires ainsi que sur la page
youtube filiale à y aller bertron on y
va pour cette pour cette partie qui a dû
tout à l'heure en direct de dubaï avec
ce premier mouvement de magnus larsson
dont qui joue les blancs et qui joue
d'ouverture en a eu quatre oui avait dit
tout à l'heure un peja sur l'ouverture
il ya des choses à dire alors oui parce
qu'au fond ils ont joué les deux
champions ont joué on va dire ils sont
en vie des extraits un c'est qu'ils ont
joué le pion damer le pion roi pendant
pendant les dix premières parties de ce
championnat du monde ça prouve quoi ça
prouve d'abord qui sont très bien
préparés c'était la question quand on
varie quand même ces ouvertures et ses
grands systèmes de ça permet d'être
moins sensible à la préparation
théorique adverse et puis
on va le voir très vite notre ami on
continue peut continuer la partie donc
la c1 une réponse y mettrez casser un
début du pion roi classique et on va le
voir très vite
car le cesne s'attendait au prochain
coup à la défense petrov à ça s'appelle
la défense petrov ou défense russe
c'était pas mal pour un russe
effectivement qui russe en rappel vous
avez les drapeaux j'ai effectivement
dessous mais au cas où vous l'auriez pas
remarqué ces drapeaux de la russie
exactement et donc vous allez voir que
maintenant karl scène qui a un avantage
terrible de trois parties davance de
l'hymen pas
3 3 0 si on compte pas les parties
nulles ce qui est un avantage fous là le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il est
en confiance ben ils viennent répondre à
une partie de la même manière quand on
est à égalité voir quand on est derrière
l'adversaire quand on a trois points
d'avancé on va vous arrêter vous vous
avancez presque trop vite mais c'est
vous avez dit la remarque judicieuse
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui je pense
que sincèrement
nepomniachi à la tête sous l'eau on
verra plus tard la fameuse sixième
partie que
que karlsson a gagné il ya de ça
quelques jours partie titanesque qui a
duré huit heures qu'a duré 136 coups il
a littéralement non seulement gagné la
partie ouvert le score mais il a assommé
son adversaire parce qu'on verra cette
partie tous dans toutes les phases
c'était c'était vraiment un combat de
titans est donc maintenant il pourrait
ouvrir la position mais il a un tel
avantage qui dit à epône iasi c'est à
toi de faire comme si bien le chercher
lui qui t'en prends dirigera donc là il
joue ça c'est on va voir la suite de
coups pouvaient avancer sylvain tout à
fait s'en servent à la nation hantée six
salles a donc là il joue ça on pouvait
jouer cavalier f3 mais sait on va pas
rentrer dans le détail de ses défenses
petrov personnes préfèrent oui je vis là
il a une idée très précise et là ils
jouent dames 2 laquelle laquelle elle a
donc le prochain coup joué là il ça cool
cavaliers il ya qu un seul coup c'est de
jouer ce qu'elle jouer et et bien sûr
maintenant
vous allez on va voir dans les coups qui
suit vous pouvez continuer voilà il va
d'abord ils menacent la casse des cinq
donc née ponia shiva la contrôler en
enlevant cents cavaliers et là on voit
que les dames vont s'échanger c'est à
dire qu'on est au jeu par garde
exactement au 6è 7è coût est déjà
quasiment les dames si un participant on
est au
10e
3/6 enfin de 12 mouvement et des six
coups 7e coup en tout cas très très très
rapidement dans l'ouverture et les dames
vont s'échanger et donc c'est au fond
avec cette variante on va continuer là
est donc la main qui sont les deux ici
qui sait l'état mais aussi ils les ont
pas échangé immédiatement non non parce
que ça change pas grand chose il ya une
fois change l'âge et un petit chantage
donc là n'est poney qui joue les bons
coups il attaque le centre
karl scène le défend traiteraient avec
beaucoup de solidité là maintenant
qu'est-ce que commencer a continué sur
37 autres à l'aller on continue le
développement et puis là alors il va
essayer menace quelque chose un peu là
le retour aux dures en arrière doué
c'est l'idée c'est pas une menace c'est
l'idée on va essayer peut-être de mettre
le cavalier sur cette case en u6 la case
blanche devant la dame pourrait éviter
les changes des dames c'est tout ce que
ça veut dire mais au fond il n'y a pas
moyen de pas tellement moyen d'échangé
parce que alors on va voir ce que je
fais
cavalier ses bras et là il a l'a pas
fait a reçu jeudi peut t'aider j'ai
changé lui même qui échangent les dames
ça veut dire quand même que dans cette
position en faisant ça en faisant ce
coup peut-être qu'ils étaient
indispensables
je pense que nepomniachi est réellement
a été assommé 1 on peut pas dire on peut
jouer d'aidé on avait vu entre kasparov
et crame nigou entre dans d'autres
championnats du monde vous pouvez avoir
des milieux de jeu sans les dames
complexe mais là c'est très symétriques
et safadi la position et du coup quand
ça ne prend la dame avec le fou toujours
toujours 1,2 à sauver vous dites n'est
poney chip dépôt comme mais bon la
commission d'amm comment le sort
d'hommes on peut le comprendre il a eu
oui tu es partie difficile on va le voir
juste après mais déjà en dire quelques
mots il ya eu la journée de repos lundi
il est revenu en ces temps couper les
cheveux lui car il avait un petit anti
chine et anti catogan exactement au
dessus de au dessus du crâne il est
revenu à la surprise générale coiffer
complètement différent j'en veux dire
coiffée à la quarantaine est ce qu'il a
voulu être déstabilisé je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il est revenu
affectés dans son jeu n'a pas réussi à
il était comme s'en sont fait très
attention à sa coiffure mais il a perdu
avec son côté gauche il a perdu
puisqu'il a perdu cette partie terrible
dont on parle et après grosso modo il a
perdu la 8e et la 9e c'est que cette
partie on la regardera tout à l'heure
mais ça c'est lé plus passionnante que
celle de jeu que celle qu'ont qu'on
regarde là on va accélérer sur un
réacteur sur celle ci c'est
effectivement tout se passe là elle veut
revenir c'est pendant cinq parties mais
peut on va l'appeler nepos et une épaule
yashin série dépôt il et il tient ni
tient parce que le type ou sip ou 6
pouces car le sel il a visiblement très
préparée mais au fond on croyait non pas
tout le monde pensait car ce n était
favori 1 soyons clairs mais n'est pas
inquiète quand même un joueur doué c'est
un joueur qui peut être fantasque qui
peut avoir des idées est quand même dans
la première partie il se battait et puis
et puis il a remporté le tour des
candidats tout simplement on peut le
c'est à dire que les challengers sont
affrontés entre eux et à l'issue de cet
affrontement c'est lui qui en est sorti
vainqueur de tous les challengers du
champion du languedoc en scène un petit
mot sur ce tournoi des candidats l'on
s'y perd donc la partie se déroule est
là c'était le deuxième le deuxième on va
parler du secret de ce tournoi c'était
quand même le grand maître français
maxime vachier lagrave qui l'a mené
alors c'est un tournoi terrible
puisqu'il a commencé lors du premier
confinement à la moitié du tournoi
c'était le français maxime vachier
lagrave qu'on surnomme aussi mail mvl
dans le milieu des échecs qui était en
tête et puis là finissent seconds ce
tournoi c'était pour nous c'est terrible
parce que maxime vachier lagrave est un
joueur talentueux qui pouvait avoir une
chance je pense que s'il n'y avait pas
eu le confinement et l'épidémie il
aurait certainement là aussi il y avait
une dynamique
qui allait dans son sens à la fin du
premier tournoi mais à ce jeu ce tournoi
qui s'est jouée sur quasiment
18 mois ça a été terrible mais enfin on
peut pas les bénéfices s'est qualifié il
n'a pas triché ils méritent il mérite
aujourd'hui d'être face à carl scène il
méritait sa place à nous en sommes au
17e coup d'éclat bertrand alors on
reprend le fil à regarder on a regardé
non seulement ils ont chirurgie les
dames et après ils ont changé une tour
sur la colonne ouverte là vous allez
voir dans les coups suivants pouvait
continuer sylvain
dont classe et on réactive aujourd'hui
ouverte là on garde les cas centrale on
veut surtout pas ici dans cette partie
car le sait bien il un tel avantage dans
le match guy dit à l'autre mais vient
qu'un seul il est tranquille mais il a
vraiment avoir un peu attendre c'est
quand même intéressant pour
nous pour nous autres les joueurs moyens
de voir comme on centralise le roy on
est en finale on centralise leur mission
avec karl scène on sait ce qu'on fait
maintenant laon seul est diffile centre
avec ce dernier coup et là maintenant il
n'y a plus qu'une seule pièce qui n'est
alors on chasse le cavalier pour vous
voir vous allez comprendre pour pouvoir
maintenant développer la seule dernière
pièce qui n'était pas en jeu chez les
blancs c'est à dire le fou qui en jeu et
on propose encore un échange c'est une
partie
vers heureusement qu'on n'a pas eu à
faire un vrai direct là dessus parce
qu'on se serait un peu ennuyé
mais bon un peu mal de le voir en
accéléré voilà rejoint d'accélérer
échange des fous pris par le cavalier 4
donc là on chasse alors on chasse là
cavalier pouvait certainement s'échanger
contre mais bon carlos ngân guerre entre
le fou il aurait pu il faut le savoir
mais le froid sa garde et la case f4
donc ils cherchent ils cherchent pas
l'âge et cherche aucun preuve aucun
chercheur les problèmes cherchent ils à
rien la trempe en avant ce mercredi là
trois points d'avancé en avance on
cherche pas l'oncle a exactement trois
points d'avancé on attend donc la
recherche est là malgré tout ils
essaient d'y jouer un coup et c'est
comme d'avoir un peu l'initiative en
essayant de frapper sur la structure
mais il se casse pas la tête il la
défend protection ça qu'est ce qu'il a
fait on centralise le roi aussi parce
qu'on est au fond on est dans une
position quasiment de finale or si on
miroir un bernard maman oui
je peux pas dire mieux pas dire que ça
c'est effectivement les rois y a qu'à
voir la position
à ce stade est au 25e coupe il a dit
vous allez voir bientôt carlson va
vouloir mettre sa tour en jeu et ça ne
manque pas dont on connaît la partie
mais toutes façons tout tout vient alors
qu'est-ce qui nous inventer notre
famille parle voilà là on avance ici on
joue un coup de consolidation la r ça
c'est l'alléchant général en jeu quand
ça on va échanger un maximum de pions et
de pièces pour on va voir la suite de la
partie très rapidement donc et fillon le
lait noir gagne un pion mais simplement
au momentanément puisque tout de suite
car la scène se venge sur le pion à chis
avec la tour voilà c'est ici voilà
on échange encore change de jour des
fous voilà exactement là là toi est
attaqué en fait le chèque c'est voilà
cavaliers quasiment est obligé de
revenir on va gagner karlsson gagne
moment tellement momentanément un pion
mais tout de suite on le re gagne
on va vous et accélérer silva parce que
ça arrive au bout de la partie il n'y a
rien d'extraordinaire il ya rien
d'extraordinaire là dessus
quelques déplacements on centralise le
roi il s'enfuit sans fil roi et on
arrive à la fin de la partie bertrand
s'est terminé sur un match nul oui nul
aux échecs c'est pas 00 d'ailleurs ses
amis points oui puisque c'est chacun des
joueurs mais ça on partage le point qui
était qui était en jeu et surtout là ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que dans ce cas
présent ce match nul est davantage très
clairement busquin scène il n'y a plus
que quatre parties à jouer
donc il faut pour que carlson reste
champion du monde et faut qu'il fasse
cet ennemi sur 14 il a déjà six et demi
et pour être encore plus simple plus
clair il reste quatre parties il
faudrait que pour que
[Musique]
le russe n'est pas uni à chi et égaliser
frais qui gagne trois parties sur les
quatre dernières
on est alors au fond on aimerait
peut-être pour le spectacle pour le
spectacle mais je il va voir dans les
parties on va en discuter
il s'est battu dans les premières
parties nepomniachi mais karl scène
était toujours là toujours là donc il ya
trois grandes phases on va leur dire
encore le début de partie où là c'est
l'analyse c'est le travail théorique et
on peut dire quand même que c'est hocine
quand même dans l'équipe de carl 7 vous
avez un français vous avez grand le
grand maître laurent frayssinet qui est
déjà venu sur notre plate bien sûr on a
envie il ya quelques années qui a été
quand même top 25 mondial il ya de ça
quelques années
qui épateront chess 24 aujourd'hui et
qui est le second dans l'un des gens là
des entraîneurs et ils ont fait un super
travail ils ont fait un super travail
particulièrement je trouve avec les
pièces noires ou
dans la partie espagnole puisqu'au début
des pony achi a joué surtout on peut
peut-être regarder une autre alors oui
quel parti est-ce qu'on peut regarder
l'intrant pour illustrer vos alors
enregistrer vos projets mais là je peux
plus aller les chercher
non ac c'est là là là on va mais voilà
la fin des parties précédentes en raison
des détails et être tel soumettre on
regarde mais alors quand on perd les
échos comment comment elle a comme je
fais ça ah ouais voilà alors oui mais ça
ouvre une nouvelle nouvelle méthode en
plein écran à bertrand personnalisé à
les y aller dit faites le pour moi en
faire qu on fait ça faites-le pour moi
va pas s'embêter alors aux valeurs honda
et là ça va être plus simple pour moi
alors voilà
encore un petit peu pour remonter là
comment tu fais pour remonter
ici voilà j'y suis c'est bon comme souci
voilà on va regarder par exemple on va
passer on va s'arrêter sur la première
partie ouais première partie qui est
assez qui est assez on va regarder
prête pas attention à
ça ce sont les gimmicks de notre module
d'analysé que vous entendez alors on va
garantir selon quelle partie à ça c'est
la première simplement qui va finir par
part par une maison qui je voulais blanc
sait s'il pourrait nepomniachi
kerdellant
donc on averses l'échiquier est regardée
aux 4/5 nepomniachi on va aller
relativement vite vous parliez aberrant
de l'ouverture espagnol va là on est on
est pas c'est pas exactement ça chers
amis c'est le cas tu sais ça c'est ce
pion là ce pion devant le roi des deux
cases l'autre
pardon up à la symétrie donc pardon
symétrie
alain cavalier f3
parler d'ouverture espagnol ça c'est
alors attardé cavaliers
si la partie espagnole parce que
l'espagnol on est partis espagnols hors
hui lopes parce que c'était hélas
maintenant le dernier coup ça c'est le
coup typique fou b5 ici ça c'est
encore voilà ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
la partie espagne alors ça existe depuis
enfin en tout cas ça a été analysé la
première fois par un moine
espagnole qui s'appelle we lopes en 470
580 donc c'est pas tout à fait nouveau
et c'est surtout la tasse de thé de tous
les grands champions et de tous les
grands champions depuis un siècle et
demi ok pourquoi c'est très efficace
alors pourquoi en faire quoi en quelques
mots sachant que c'est la tasse de thé
en même temps c'est peut-être la partie
l'accordage le système le plus
stratégique parce que ici vous avez on
l'a vu on place un pion au centre les
noirs en ressortira en regardant par
l'ouverture donc on le rappelle on
commence toujours par les blancs c'est
pour les blancs qui jouent en premier
aux échecs évidemment donc on ouvre ici
hop comme ça 5le d'options se font face
voilà on est là on sort le cavalier
vincent lecavalier de l'autre côté
voilà que l'on défend le pion 1,5 et ici
avec ce coup la partie espagnole
vous allez faire pression sur un
directement sur le pion aux cinq qui est
finalement le l'armature de la position
noirs ancrés donc alors c'est simple à
partir de ça vous avez des tas de
variantes d'état de variantes donc on va
on va voir et là surtout on va regarder
les coûts sylvain joué par donc à 6 on
va regarder va aller vite sur le sur une
séquence de coûts tout ça est un trait
analysé as tu vas 4 à 6 x 4 on recule on
rejoint alors allez-y bertrand alors à 6
bardot et vous le spécialiste y voilà
j'ai par les lecteurs c'est rapide à 6 x
4 donc cavalier
f 6 on va aller vite petit rock
certainement voilà petit rock on va
aller vite sur cette séquence de coups
et on va essayer de l'analyser fouet
cette annonce là je dis une bêtise alors
attend
tout rien peut-être non alors attends
c'est moi qui
pourquoi ça marche pas ça car si ce
petit rock
attendre et c'est comme je suis sur deux
ordinateurs qui avait officié ce petit
rock mais pourquoi on peut pas jouer ça
là à oui d'accord fouet celle donc ça
c'est possible à la fois cette
tour e 1
b 5
bientôt chers amis le fou alors le fou
pardon recul parce qu'ils gèrent
pourquoi b57 ou noir d'où là c'est parce
que c'est moi qui utilise mal la souris
est là alors là
lance arrête un tout petit peu et là
effectivement
c'est donc caleçon
quand sam des bonis achi qui a les
blancs
alors b6 sauver 3,9 petit rock petit
rock pardon excusez moi hélas ici on a
en jouant ce coup ce dernier coup petit
rock on va regarder sais pas si vous
voyez c'est aux menaces la fameuse
attaque marshall de là
de l'espagnol alors on va encore une
fois c'est ya des mais il ya des
milliards danalyse là dessus on va
donner l'idée la partie espagnole est
une partie hautement stratégique pour ce
qu'on vous disait au début c'est hier
qu'on essaye les blancs indirectement
font pression sur le centre le pion aux
5 on voit peut-être la flèche à l'écran
il se complète d'un soutien et 5 mai
vers ou au mieux au début du 20e siècle
il ya un grand maître américain qui
s'appelait marshall qui a vu qu'on
pouvait avec un gambit un sacrifice de
pions dynamiser la position des noirs si
elle ne pas souffrir il ya un terme
qu'on emploie c'est la torture espagnol
la torture espagnol c'est à dire que si
effectivement on suit les canons
classiques du développement on peut se
retrouver à être torturé pendant des
heures donc au fond peut dire que le
joueur qui utilisent la partie espagnole
a tout intérêt à le faire bâle est celui
qu'elle est blanc a tout intérêt à le
faire parce qu'il sait qu'il sa
stratégie repose sur quelque chose de
très sain de très solides au québec du
couac du coup un certain joueurs ont
vraiment travaillé à développer une part
à brendan sens on peut rappeler c'est un
contre gambie 1 gambie 1 contre gambie
puisque c'est fait avec les noirs mais
là l'idée du courant pop hip hop hop hop
qu'ai-je fait hop il est renversant pars
dans l'idée du contre gambie cède un
moment donné c'est de jouer très très
vite ce coup 17 des 5 2 contre attaquer
au centre au prix d'un pion et là c'est
toute une série de finesse on va pas
rentrer là dedans mais c'est tout ça
c'est travailler et règlements sur
ravailler pendant pendant des semaines
par les deux équipes des deux champions
pour savoir ils savent tout ce que je
viens de dire il n'y a pas besoin d'être
un super grand maître pour le savoir il
suffit d'être un bon joueur pour le
savoir tout cas de connaître les canons
de la stratégie donc ils savent que ça
peut en tout cas la tech marshall c'est
au fond c on peut la menacer on peut
menacer donc il va jouer notre ami n'est
pas eu un anti marshall avec des nuances
qui rend difficile ce coup tout de suite
alors maintenant on va peut-être
continuer à regarder la partie mais
simplement quelques coups pour vous
montrer que
donc après ce coup là alors là déjà une
nouveauté regardez ça ça manque quand
même que dès la première partie karl
scène est très agressif parce qu'en
faisant ce coup qui va menace de prendre
le pion il sacrifie ce pion aux 5 voilà
donc c'est lui qui ont selon lui
interdit de jouer la marshall classique
mais au fond il a préparé quelque chose
d'autre
nepomniachi va prendre l'option 1 parce
qu'au fond la meilleure il a mon avis a
peut-être travailler la chose mais on
sait aussi que la meilleure réputation
d'un sacrifice c'est son acceptation
alors il faut le gober le pion mais il
faut savoir le recracher au bon moment
donc on regarde la partie qui avait les
prend 1,5
évidemment on se
on se débarrasse et l'idée de carlson
soucier d'eux s'est débarrassé des lits
d'éliminer le fou le fameux fou espagnol
et est maintenant donc la
foux bessette on joue ça on frappe sur
le pion et 400 qui sont paradoxalement
ce sont les noirs qu'on a pu noah mais
ce sont eux qu'on l'initiative
donc là il faut le défendre ce il a
défendu la manière la plus solide
possible en créant une structure de
pions instructeur de pion central et là
rebelote et dix de der on va s'arrêter
là c'est une sorte de marshall différé
c'est à dire que après dans cette
position au fond pendant quelques coups
car le sel va jouer qu'un pion de moins
mais c'est lui qui dit c'est lui qui
dicte quand même malgré tout le langage
le cours du jeu donc au fond il avait
alors ce qui est formidable il arrive à
garder la main il a été beaucoup il a
été beaucoup dit que koné peau justement
a utilisé cette stratégie de lentilles
marchal sur toutes ces parties en tout
cas toutes les parties où il en avait
l'occasion mais ça fait peur qu'est ce
que vous en pensez ça est ce que est ce
qu'il ya une raison parce que à
l'évidence à l'évidence ça n'a pas porté
ses fruits alors merci non mais c'est
improbable s'est éteint à c'est une
question cruciale c'est une crise qui
reste c'est presque une question
qui dépasse le jeu d'échec c'est à dire
d'abord faut-il rentrer dans les
préparations l'autre faut-il avoir peur
de ce qu'on vit marshall objectivement
depuis quelques années la théorie des
grandes variantes delà de la partie
espagnole et ça depuis depuis même
kasparov qui n'a jamais accepté de
granby marshall au fond ça remisé au
placard les grandes variantes stratégie
parce que les meilleurs joueurs du monde
avec les pièces blanches au fond ont
peur de laisser l'initiative à
l'adversaire donc alors maintenant votre
question corollaire c'est dire est ce qu
il a bien fait
nous évidemment c'est facile de dire à
la 10e partie mené 3-0 qu'il n'a pas
bien fait mais qu'elle était avait t'il
d'autres solutions je
regarde ta clé aujourd'hui je le seul
parmi les grands champions qui récemment
a accepté de rentrer là dedans 1 pour
parler vulgairement c'est radjabov
mais
c'était annoncé c'est le seul peut-être
peut-être mais il ya peut-être d'autres
manières en réalité le problème c'est
que
il a mal fait au fond ou alors il
n'aurait pas dû jouer peut-être le pion
le pion roi alors le pion roi c'est
agressif on sait depuis fischer best buy
test on connaît son expression le
meilleur pas il aimait se secoue
kasparov était un joueur aussi de quatre
fa tous les grands champions mais c'est
vrai quand même qu'il me semble qu'on
peut plus pêcher en eaux troubles avec
la partie anglaise un c4 la partie du
pion d'armes ou même cavalier f3 ramener
jouer cavalier f3 il n'est pas le seul
et d'ailleurs on va le voir duy parce
que je crois qu'on va pas encore une
fois on peut pas passer deux heures sur
cette partie mais simplement on comprend
bien que au fond des quand même avec le
recul dès la première partie car le
samedi ça va être un combat jeunes
refusent pas le combat une autre il a
été impérial alors certes on peut se
dire il est alors il il a perdu vos
qu'une aucune partie il en a même gagné
3 sur les sur les 10 est ce que vraiment
il est intouchable
le temps
que toute notre vie est ce qu'on va
vivre sous le règne de wade comme ça
alors
jusqu'à la fin des jours il y les
joueurs encore un comme ça il a 30 ans
comme nepomniachi mais il se trouve que
vous avez un jeune français qui
s'appelle ali reza fait firouz hague il
vient d'être c'est un iranien qui vient
d'être naturalisé qui est un surdoué et
qui est numéro deux mondial numéro deux
mondial juste derrière magnus clics
seulement à 18 ans il s'est qualifié
pour le prochain les tournois des
candidats n'avaient pas l'âge pour
participer au 1er mai ils étaient pas
oui il était il avait apprécié dans le
précédent en plus on a raconté tout à
l'heure que tout ça c'est joué pendant
les confinements donc je sais pas facile
et puis le fait quand même bien d'être
devenus français d'être soutenu
aujourd'hui par la ville de chartres en
france et par la france ça va
certainement lui donner les moyens de
mieux jouer sachant qu'en diront pendant
un temps comme le jeu d'échecs a été
plus ou moins
interdit donc enfin en tout cas
aujourd'hui il représente la france il
est numéro deux mondial il sait vient de
se qualifier pour le tournoi des
candidats donc on va dire c'est le
tournoi de qualification suprême car
emporté donc un dépôt cette année n'est
pas correctement la prestance et
peut-être que pour le prochain c'est un
vrai sport pour la france pour moi je
pense que c'est celui à reste que sept
prochains championnats du monde on parle
déjà on enterre celui là avant parce que
ce sera quoi vous rendez compte 35 ans
même incroyable un champion du monde
d'échecs français ça serait quelque
chose d'abord ça serait ici par heather
naturalisés se serait alors on a déjà eu
des champions du monde je dirais
franco-russe et les kalenjins
est ce parce qu'ils avaient été
champions du monde russes il est devenu
français après donc ça c'est pas une
nouveauté en france mais surtout ce
serait quand même un beau symbole parce
que alireza fille rosa était pas obligé
de choisir la france je pense que
c'était un choix chez lui parce qu'il
était bien accueillie et qu'en plus il
est iranien c'est à dire qu'ils les
perses et comme chacun sait le jeu
d'échecs qui a des origines perce le
chat tu ranges shamamatt échec et mat ça
vient de chamade c'est à dire leurs
châles que le shah d'iran c'est le chat
il faut tuer le roi shy'm or le peuple
et non pas le petit schéma comme dans
molière mais le chat le shah d'iran donc
ce sera moins à mon avis il est il pour
être un challenger très dangereux pour
deux ans laure dans deux ans il y aura
20 ans ça sera peut-être un peu court
mais je pense que je en tout cas ce que
je sais ce que je sais sans trahir c'est
que laurent frayssinet que l'un des
entraîneurs de de carl scène connaît le
talent de fille rosa est dit que
il pourrait c'est possible que ce soit
lui qui lui qui soit le premier
véritablement à pouvoir le défier a eu
des chances raisonnables de l'inquiéter
alors est ce que ce sera dans deux ans
est ce que ce sera dans quatre ans à 18
ans on est jeune on ira là-bas mais je
pense en tout cas il a un talent fou moi
j'ai regardé certaines de ses parties il
est il est extraordinaire parce que même
dans des positions parfois difficile il
arrive à insuffler
des variantes complexe il est toujours à
la recherche de l'initiative alors
évidemment face face à carl scène qui
dunke d'une solidité à toute épreuve ça
va peut-être être compliqué mais je
pense que là on a on a véritablement un
grand espoir mondial est alors à
l'envers ce n'est pas là-dessus il a été
alors est ce vent l'a dit pierre poutine
le voulait vainqueur vladimir poutine
vous voulez que le champion du monde
redevienne russe vous faites allusion un
papier que j'ai signé toute sa famille
qui dit qui donna la parole admira
skripchenko qui est une quête et six
fois championne de france et qui est
venu qui est venu dans vos studios pour
justement parler de ce championnat du
monde
il soutient poutine soutient d'epône
iasi je crois qu'il soutient n'importe
quel grand m us qui pourrait détrôner
karl scène c'est quand même leur jeu ils
ont été sachant sachant quand même que
de 48 à jusqu'à jusqu'à fisher et puis
même après avec karpov et kasparov
puis après avec cram nique ils ont quand
même dominé outrageusement le jeu
d'échecs au xxème siècle un sûr et il ya
quand même et c'est quand même encore
j'ai quand même une une discipline
nationale et hérite évidemment de
l'époque soviétique mais qu'il ait rien
qui est qui avait hérité aussi cette
pratique des intellectuels comme stall
stall stall avant du temps du régime
tsariste
donc il l'a soutenu
est-ce qu'il a été décevant alors mais
pour on en parle au passé comme si la
rencontre était terminée c'est pas tout
à fait le cas mais on a dit que ont déjà
dit au début se relève que ce serait
très difficile est-ce que d'ores et déjà
il n'a gagné aucune partie est ce que
pour un match de championnat du monde
c'était souvent
objectivement c'est décevant je pense
qu'il n'est pas à son meilleur niveau en
ce qu'il est déçu mais je dis là on va
regarder la partie
mais la partie à zéro on va regarder la
partie décisive une partie titanesque
alors bertrand je vous laisse là m
pendant ce temps je rappelle qu'il est
17h11 et que nous sommes en direct
toujours sur filière volaille pour faire
le sur ce championnat du monde d'échecs
qui se déroule en ce moment à dubaï
depuis une semaine et demi maintenant si
je me trompe pas dû concernant la date
de début de championnat et que nous
sommes avec bertrand guyard le
spécialiste échec ici au figaro pour
revivre les temps forts de cet
affrontement qui en est à sa dixième
partie et qui est déjà on disait à
l'instant bien bien avancés en faveur de
bail jusqu'en seine en quel parti je
faisais la sixième partie et magnus
carlsen à l'eiblen magnus carlsen à
l'eiblen donc statuer dans ce cas si je
me trompe pas on va oui inversée
l'échiquier donc mal en quart-de-finale
et blanc et alors on revient on revient
à votre précédente question 0,6 il a
jusqu'à ce moment-là il ya déjà cinq
parties car nepomniachi a quand même
montré qu'il était du niveau du
championnat du monde il a résisté et
d'ailleurs un parcours il a réparti les
jeux ne sont pas fait les jeux ne sont
pas faits
il a montré quand même que parfois ils
subissaient mais que parfois il a eu des
positions très supérieure il joue avec
quand même beaucoup de confiance un
assez vite souvent effectivement ils
rêvent beaucoup il se lève il et il
avait l'air décontracté
et au fond il y avait beaucoup avec 5
nuls il y avait beaucoup d'aficionados
du jeu d'échecs qui dira d'abord c'est
un peu pénible tout c'est nul et c'est
le jeu d'échecs soyons clairs c'est un
certain niveau il s'est beaucoup de
particules 1 les amateurs à mon sens
sans oublier que
parties nulles parti égalité si on
partira pas partie c'est sa vieillesse
et enfants français il ya un mauvais jeu
de mots mais des partis qui finissent
par le partage du point
le premier match entre karpov et
kasparov
il ya 48 parties il n'y a que huit
parties décisives ouais un 5-3 et
phoenix 5-3 donc malgré tout c'est très
compliqué alors
alors alors cette seconde partie allez
on va là on va la suivre l'interview z
carlson lui choisi dans cette partie de
terribles il choisit le pion dames 1 et
donc au fond prochain coup
là ça va ah là où je citerai solide qui
avaient des f3 la partie symétrique et
laon jour ne pas transférer par leur
pardon pardon pardon donc
voilà exactement bravo hélas là on est
là bien 17 valasse ce pion lattes de
case
là et là là effectivement dans cette
position il joue j'ai trois pions g2 g3
quai on va appeler ça la catalane
c'était long mais son faux fuyants kétou
et c'est un cetain paradoxalement là
aussi depuis depuis l'ère cramique mais
même avant lui
s'éteint c'est un système qui est très
très pernicieux avec les blancs sert
qu'on retarde un tout petit peu l'attak
au centre le fou va être très très bien
placé angers 2 sur cette case sur la
cage chez deux quand il va se développer
et
c'était aussi dans une partie précédente
il y avait aussi une partie à scène
assez animé où karl scène avait pris
d'abord l'avantagé puis l'avait perdue
ou même nepomniachi avait pris un gros
apparemment alors là aussi disons un peu
l'analyse avec les avec les les
ordinateurs parfois ça donne une
mauvaise c'est d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'ont fait pas ici ça donne une
mauvaise compréhension de la tension de
la tension et du combat d'attention du
combat parce que parfois l'ordinateur
voit un avantage matériel et au fond
donnent un bel avantage à tel ou tel
adversaire mais pratiquement
devant l'échiquier ça se passe pas
exactement comme ça donc en tout cas
alors on continue pardon pardon pardon
revenons à nos moutons
alors oui pardon donc voilà puis aussi
ce donc là bas donc là jusque là on va
on va aller assez vite passé une partie
on vous le dit tout de suite qui va
durer 136 coups donc on va
pour l'instant c'est normal on se
développe petit rock petit rock tout ça
on fait au fond on tient le centre on
développe ses pièces et là là encore
karl scène joue b2 b3 il y aurait
peut-être pu jouer des pions ces deux c4
pour attaquer le sens mais au fond là au
corps il choisit un système un peu lent
mais lent ça veut pas dire que c'est pas
c'est pas venir venimeux il veut au fond
je pense que
peut-être le dire at il après le match
mais je pense que dans cette partie va
le montrer ils voulaient que le combat
soit sans merci et donc qu'il veut
reporter les problèmes au milieu de
partie là
bien première première décision tu veux
pas attaquer au centre moi je prends un
peu l'initiative c'est ce que c'est ce
que veut dire le dernier coup d'épaulé à
qui on échange
et on contre attaque le change le clou
alors pardon excuse moi excusez moi
sylvain non oui il a repris avec le fou
bien c'est sous la lave tout prend hélas
pions pardon là ils attaquent le centre
avec le pion il prend
là il va jouer la dame là pour pouvoir
reprendre avec la dame parce qu'il ya un
clouage on peut pas reprendre le pion on
va aller vite là dessus on reprend il
continue finalement son sens à son
chantage
pardon pardon pardon
il continue son chantage
je suivais pas par exemple que par
exemple cette séquence de coûts est vrai
ta ble ment été analysés à la maison
avant pardon voulait que je revienne
donc on était la dame la
dame la dame là cavalier là et là on
développe le cavalier et là je pense
qu'on reprend avec le cavalier voilà
on reprend avec lecavalier
là encore une fois
bon oui on va aller on va aller on va
essayer d'aller un peu vite donc on
attaque la dame la dame
on
noir est tout à fait tout à fait décente
ici un comme ça vu lé nez
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a joué là on
chasse le cavalier qui revient là quand
même
cette décision elle est pas anodine
c'était à qu'il aurait pu échanger les
pièces il garde les pièces au centre là
on a quand même position on a vu tout à
l'heure la dernière partie où j'ai
changé tout tout de suite là non on
garde un maximum de tension et à vous
avez quasiment vous avez encore toutes
les pièces sur l'échiquier est très très
peu très très peu de
là le fou qui était attaqué recul on
développe la tour vient sur la colonne
est là
chers amis je ne sais pas pourquoi alors
alors il a repris avec le pion vous y
êtes il a non pardon jardin tout pour
autant pardon alors où est tu je suis là
tu es là donc là il a joué tour là
et là maintenant car le scène à échanger
et là il ya une décision un peu
apparemment
en tout cas
responsable de notre ami nepomniachi
puisqu'il va reprendre avec le pion
déstructurant quand même son rock et sa
structure alors que peut-être que la
reprise avec la dame était tout à fait
jouable mais là encore une fois on va
pas s'attarder là dessus on continue
on continue
e
on a échangé
reprend on attaque la dame
voilà bravo la dame madame va aller
là-bas bravo
or des pièces le fou le roi reprend
j'imagine
dames échec la machine non d'un échec si
d'un échec leur war le droit va reculer
mais centralisée et on va tricher un
petit peu on va regarder l'évaluation de
notre logiciel qui est l'un des
meilleurs du monde mine de rien et là
vous avez une égalité c'est à dire une
égalité devant l'échiquier la dame noire
est très centralisé le fou aussi la dame
blanche et pas spécialement bien placé
et ben pourtant notre ami nepomniachi va
perdre cette partie mais va il va perdre
cette partie dans plus de cent coups
donc on va continuer on va continuer
donc là elle est décentralisée on
revient
là on prend un peu laissé d'un peu
l'espace on centralise
rebelote et la sas est une sas est une
vraie décision parce que la regrettons
voilà parce que là au fond maintenant là
aussi ça montre la volonté de carlson de
jouer quand même pour le gain c'est qui
va échanger saddam contre deux tours et
on va alors prendre alors pardon
et on s'est vite on fait d'amour prendre
part dont dame prend tour à
tour prend
reprend et là on a un déséquilibre on a
en tout cas on s'est pas un déséquilibre
matériel on a plutôt un matériel
hétérogène c'est à dire les deux tours
val la dame
cavaliers contrefous
mais on va très vite se rendre compte
que au fond et on va le voir sud de la
partie c'est c'est plutôt avec ce
matériel là c'est karl cède qui aura
toujours des possibilités
d'améliorer sa position il va le faire
de façon
chirurgicale sans jamais ce sans jamais
sans jamais sans jamais se s'énerver
prendre de risques alors voilà la dame
nepomniachi dans cette position
l'ordinateur il dit que tout ça c'est
très jouable il attaque le pion donc
karl scène le pouce ou simplement pour
pas le perdre pour fixer la structure
alors on en est là là on chasse le fou
il vient sur la case centrale donc là et
là vous allez c'est bon
là alors ça aussi ça c'était peut-être à
coup un peu un coup un peu difficile
parce que ça fixe eu la faiblesse est ce
qu'on appelle le pire échec est une
faiblesse elle est fixée
la regarder il se casse pas la tête
karlsson pearl scène il va il attend il
joue un coup droit souvent on ne joue
pas des coudes pions pour pour attendre
ça c'est possible on joue plutôt des
coups de roi pour parce que ça change
pas grand chose à en tirer
alors là on quand même notre ami n'est
pas ni la chine ne fait pas rien mais
paradoxalement on le voit quand même se
coupent qui paraît agressif il ya une
jauge on a une jauge c'est facile pour
nous de juger qui attaquent le pion et
paradoxalement pas un bon coup
à cause de la de cette réponse est là
paradoxalement c'est le seul moment où
dans la partie c'est facile pour nous de
le constater parce que les logiciels
analyse
paradoxalement ici et fallait jouer
alain temps avant il a joué je cherche
non non c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
revient la position il a joué toi là
voilà là c'est là dans cette position il
fallait jouer
tour peu importe il fallait jouer un
autre coup car lé 7 jouent pas le bon
coup
[Musique]
alors non parce que ta phu prend pions
d'abord
voilà la tour prend dame là
paradoxalement cette position est très
jouable pour les relais pour les blacks
pendant
que
on
un peu long je suis désolé mais cette
partie est longue et la voilà ça a
priori c'est aussi les coudes que c'est
facile pour nous de critiquer tous ses
coups mais au fond il prend le centre
avec le pion il a réussi à créer pour
l'instant il ya quand même un pion
passer pour un an et 4g pas si vous
voyez qu'on doit pour on a l'impression
que tout ça ça se passe bien pour poney
poney achi et à mon avis il a dû
souffrir terriblement dans cette partie
parce que au fond visuellement on a
l'impression tout ça s'arrête là pour
lui qu'il a même des chances et au fond
c'est pas tout à fait vrai
voilà on revient il est revenu en c2
et là paradoxalement regardez c'est le
dernier coup dam des cinq qui paraît un
coup de centralisation qui visuellement
paraît très bon
pour des raisons qui seraient trop
longues analysé ici
ce n'est pas un bon coup
là
à l'adil joue les coups agressifs
nepomniachi et par dax allemand ses
coups agressifs c'est là où vous voulez
quand même toute la force de que deux
karts scène c'est que on a l'impression
qui fait pas grand chose mais il est
toujours en contrôle toujours en
contrôle toujours en contrôle donc on
continue et vous y êtes donc là il joue
or l'homme ayant là on va voir ça par
exemple ça fixe là ça parle on va voir
ça c'est une séquence et elle peut un
peu extraordinaire
ici il a eu six voyez vous il ya plus
que ça si la dame avait pris le cavalier
si la dame et la tour est pris et alors
regardez bien je peux me permettre on va
regarder simplement une vague à chaque
fois je suis mais vraiment mauvais j'ai
vraiment un mauvais
gars c'est pas tout bertrand elle
m'avait un mauvais manière heures de
show et si par exemple c'est parce qu'il
a joué s'il ya vu ça on aurait eu cette
finale deux tours contre dame ce pion là
et 1,4 et perdu
les deux tours vont croquer et à ce
moment là on a réussi une finale de
trois pions tref très faible contre 4
pions qui se tiennent bien contre les
deux tours ça c'est
rideau donc il peut pas jouer ça alors
comment revenons
qu'est ce que voulait faire bertrand je
voulais revenir pardon je voulais
revenez en a joué qu elle et ses cinq de
mes 4 sur dame là on va regarder on va
suivre la partie
jouer notre ami je vous rends doucement
cette souris
doucement cette souris est
doucement cette souris alors on va y
arriver
alors hop le voir ce qui s'est passé
là il a joué dans b3 au lieu de prendre
le cavalier les jouets dame b 3 il a
compris qu est-ce qu on venait de
montrer et était pas bon du tout on
continue toujours là
et alors ce qui est très rigolo c'est
qu'on a l'impression j'ai pu lire cette
partie je les ai vécues m'ont pas en
direct parce que je ne fais dans un
concert donc j'ai regardé ça sur mon
petit sur mon petit iphone vous allez
avoir des concerts de musique de
regarder le champion du monde d'échecs
discrètement sur le téléphone
discrètement parce qu'en réalité il y
avait il y avait des cordées consigne
sanitaire et de la star on peut nommer
qui était gauvin sert ses rangs et a dû
rentrer un peu plus tard et donc on
avait le temps à rassembler ses affaires
non c'était passé par passion c'est vrai
mais mais je regardais ça très
rapidement je regardais ça très rapide
moi surtout je me suis dit sans analyser
quoi que ce soit cette position elle est
terrible pour nepomniachi parce que au
fond d'accord objectivement tout cela
est égale les noirs peuvent tenir mais
au fond la structure la structure de la
position blanche et supérieur et carl
scène lui le sait et il va être très
très très prudent la suivent à calculer
doucement il va chaque fois essayé alors
on va continuer la partie donc on vous y
êtes on va essayer donc voilà donc
maintenant le fou ce recul pour laisser
la place aux pions le cavalier en kaki
de la dame à lallaing et là regardez ic2
cavaliers les formidablement bien placé
il peut aller sur cette case là sur la
case f4 il peut il contrôler quand même
les entrées ces îles et il y joue
parfaitement regardez il va sur la case
f4 il sait qu'il est inexplicable ces
deux cavaliers il va elle peut aller au
centre il peut menacer de mettre la tour
ici il peut menacer si la dame sans
vagues de frappes et cette faiblesse est
le pion il peut pas avancer regardez là
tout ils se il se fâche pas lavalas d'y
arriver alors attendez mais il avait
encore fait d'attaquer la tour la tour
s'en va là le roi au fond il faut bien
jouer quelque chose est en encore
ils se pressent pas et joue les coups à
la 10e' alors vous y avez vous parle je
vais un peu vite pour vous
un peu vite pour vous même pour moi
parfois ce que feu alors on en est et où
vous étiez vous étiez tour d un
pois chiche tour d un ca a été jouée là
il va jouer damas cat attaque la tour la
tour va rejouer ils se pressent pas se
presser pas le problème c'est qu'il n'ya
pas beaucoup de possibilités aussi pour
les noirs
fous là
là ils menacent on sait jamais de faire
feu fou prend cavaliers mais fou prend
qu'avait déjà mais parce qu'au fond
après le pion tomberait et on aurait là
la fameuse finale de tout à l'heure donc
ils menacent pas grand chose au fond
regardez ils réagir il se casse pas la
tête id il attend eh ben il attend en
même temps il est en même temps il
attend qu'on l'a rien il contrôle il
améliore ses pièces il sait exactement
donc on était la dame là le cavalier
revient le cavalier il a une autre bonne
casser la casse des quatre il va y
arriver
la dame la dame viallard
la lino de bonnes cases il y va ferrer
crainte il y est oui ici il va toutes
les essayer les cases il plaçait comme
comme un comme un général d'armée il va
placer sa cavalerie ici sa cavalerie ici
il cherche pas
donc là voilà là encore un petit coup le
roi pour voir à toi de jouer à toi de
jouer je veux savoir je veux voir une
carte donc là à là et là maintenant très
intéressant regardez bien il se dit il
sacrifie la qualité pour le pion parce
qu'il se dit jeu il veut gagner parce
qu'au fond il aurait pu continuer là on
va regarder donc faut prendre maintenant
alors d'abord non regardez là il a
calculé parce qu'il ya cette variante la
variante de la partie donc là c'est la
fallait calculer à fond donc dame prend
1 h 4 parce que le pion peut pas prendre
la dame parce que les clous et par le
fou donc là ils se trompent pas là il a
il a dû calculer karl scène au moins une
séquence de six 6 8 vous et obliger le
roi vient là donc là
maintenant alors ce qui est très rigolo
c'est il aurait pu prendre alors non le
problème c'est que il pouvait pas
sacrifier là dessus parce que de toute
façon ils auraient ils sont retrouvés
dans une mauvaise finale donc maintenant
il a réussi à se débarrasser de ce pion
donc il ya plus de problèmes maintenant
ici voilà il tient tout il tient tout
dans cette pub dans cette partie ici un
tout
non
mais dame là hélas
save est douloureux douloureux
douloureux douloureux douloureux et
on va peut-être pas jouer les 130 15 sur
les 36 coups mais ce que ce qu'il faut
savoir on va s'arrêter par exemple là
ils vont petit à petit va réussir à
échanger tous les pions et dans la
position finale ils vont se retrouver
avec cavaliers deux pions et tour contre
dame qui était intenable
soit des valves pas soi-disant
réellement par l'ordinateur sauf que au
fond c'est une partie c'est une position
terrible parce que
les blancs avaient toutes les
possibilités du monde de gagner la
partie et les noirs aucune ils ne sont
retrouvés à tenir tenir tenir et puis à
un moment donné car le sait n'a trouvé
vraiment une une variante d'études très
joli avec des sacrifices et nepomniachi
après qu'est ce qu'on a dit plus de huit
heures de jeu a fini par craquer et
cette partie elle a été cette partie qui
une vraie partie de combat qui
mériterait qu'on s'y arrête pendant des
heures a été à mon sens décisive c'était
le tournant de cette rencontre
c'est pas compliqué il ya eu les six
premières pas les cinq premières parties
fait nul
elle est
sur les quatre suivantes il prend il
perd trois fois et perd 3 fois celle
d'hier on va pas la regarder parce que
ce serait long mais il fait une gaffe
non il a perdu je pense qu'il a épuisé
les puiser la partie interminable partie
de vitesse c'est exceptionnel quand même
les partis d'une partie de tournoi deux
partis classiques c'est génial c'est
quatre heures la france va l'on sait
déjà éprouvant j'étais bien j'avais
souvent bien sûr mais aujourd'hui par
exemple ils ont joué à peine trois
heures il ya beaucoup de partis qui ce
qui se joue en trois heures mais là
c'est là c'était il voulait jouer jusque
la dernière reprise et il a quand même
montré tout son talent karl scène parce
qu'au fond ce serait quand même idiot de
dire
c'est simplement un joueur solide il a
quand même montré on l'a vu dans les
ouvertures qu'il était formidablement
bien préparés et on a montré quand même
cette faculté incroyable qu'il a dans le
milieu de partie à faire cette technique
de la transposition ou toujours il est
en contrôle et toujours e-menaces de
finalement de faire évoluer la position
comme on l'a vu dans cette partie août
il ya toujours ah oui donc là je re
sacrifie la qualité pour avoir
finalement cette finale à cavalier
cavaliers dames contre cabanon roi
cavaliers contre contre dame mais
toujours avec une meilleure structure et
puis c'est toujours la même chose on
pose un problème on pose un problème on
pose un problème est
nippon ichi a fini par craquer et ce qui
est terrible c'est qu'il a tellement
craqué dans cette partie qui ne pouvait
plus il pouvait plus se battre dans les
suivantes et on la ville et 17h35 et
voici ce qu'on pouvait vous dire sur ce
championnat du monde d'échecs qui a lieu
en ce moment à dubaï qui va encore
continuer jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
mais dont les jeux sont quasiment faits
à l'issue de ces de ces dix parties
bagus carsen qui s'acheminent
tranquillement mais sûrement vers une
nouvelle victoire il va conserver son
titre de champion du monde qu'est-ce
qu'il va remporter qu'un scène
ces gros boîtier beaucoup d'algériens sa
vie quand on est un grand maître
d'échecs de ce niveau là bas déjà je
pense que c'est quasiment un million de
dollars enfin sport de haut niveau
arrivé alors en scène c'est là pendant
le confinement ça c'est une question
intéressante il a évidemment les joueurs
d'échecs on n'avait plus le droit de
jouer la cipm ans la l1 phase est en
phase d autres donc il a monté tout un
circuit de jeux sur internet des parties
online
un tournoi avec les meilleurs sur or là
c'était les parties semi-rapides 15
minutes par donc enfin comme un
spectacle il a grillé c'était une série
de tournois est ce que c'est parce que
comme le confie quasiment duré quasiment
deux ans ils ont joué enfin 18 mois ils
ont joué une dizaine de tournois alors
dans le monde ça n'avait plus de sens
parce que le chinois jouets de chine
l'américain jouets de jouer à new york
et c'est le français jouait de jouer à
côté de chez nous mais
il ya gagné je crois de mémoire
puisqu'il a gagné non seulement les
tournois mais le le circuit il a gagné
trois cents mille trois cent mille
dollars uniquement avec ce circuit l'a
donc un joueur comme carl scène ça n'a
rien à voir avec les champions de tennis
où les champions du golfe où les encore
moins les champions de football mais
c'est c'est un joueur qui pendant bon an
mal an
rentrer son million d'heures par an voir
le voir le double est une véritable star
internationale puisque magnus carlsen en
plus il à ce
profil un peu atypique aussi au sein des
journaux chaque il ya un peu de photo
basse est aujourd'hui cité la promotion
c'est le passage obligé aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'avant les champions
soviétique c'était l'état qui les paient
ils étaient payés comme souvent
soit comme journaliste soit comme
sportif de haut niveau c'était c'est un
statut spécial ils étaient protégés et
les et il y avait à l'époque évidemment
dans les années souhaite du temps de
fisher il y avait très peu de sponsoring
c'est en tout cas c'était une notion qui
existaient mois qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le grand sponsor des
tournois en russie j'irai en asie
au delà même de la russie c'est gazprom
donc on parlait de poutine tout à
l'heure c'est une volonté du
gouvernement russe de soutenir le jeu
d'échecs qui qui se développe est déjà
très développé en russie mais qui est
très développée qui se développe en
chine et qui se développe un peu en
afrique maintenant et qui se développe
donc au fond la france à part ali reza
fille rosa qui peut être va nous
représenter dans dans deux ans est un
peu un parent pauvre alors
évidemment faire peu de cas de maxime
vachier lagrave qui est un lot dans le
top 5 mondial depuis maintenant quelques
années mais maxime fait quand même tout
90 % de ces grands tournois à l'étranger
il joue donc donc est alors maintenant
effectivement le net a apporté
énormément de choses parce que comme
nous les gens peuvent voir des tournants
direct peuvent analyser en direct
peuvent voir là évidemment on a été pris
par lé pa par la vitesse de 7 nuls
où les deux joueurs ont finalement on
peut combattu mais on peut les voir avec
les caméras on l'a déjà montré sylvain
où on voit pourquoi ils réfléchissent
pourquoi il ajouté le coup en quelques
secondes pourquoi ils s'arrêtent un
quart d'heure sur une position on a on
peut voir leur visage
et tout ça évidemment amène de l'argent
parce qu'il ya déjà des sponsors qui
sont intéressés sur internet bien sûr
merci beaucoup bertrand guyard d'avoir
commenter avec nous cette partie est les
précédentes que vous avez déjà commencé
les jours passent et on vous dis à très
bientôt sur figaro live dans une
vingtaine de minutes vous retrouvez
l'émission quotidienne point de vue
animé par vincent roux ce soir et nous
bertrand ont saisi peut-être au prochain
tour des championnats du monde au
prochain tour wade candidat peut-être
pour normalement dans 18 mois et puis
peut-être une dernière fois on a fait un
bilan la halle ou non on va pas se
revoir je pense pour ces championnats du
monde merci beaucoup meurtre en est
votre soirée à tous